okay so honestly completely unrelated to
the fact that i am currently taking a
break from university and medical school
i've recently been thinking about the
things that school has not taught me so
today i thought i'd share five things
that i learned from books that school
could never teach me let's get straight
into it so number one has got to be
learning to let small bad things happen
or learning to make mistakes i love the
suggestion of develop the habit of
letting small bad things happen
otherwise you will never find the time
for the life changing big things and i
think in school from a very young age we
are taught clearly to get even the small
things very very well and to do them
very well and even small mistakes will
take like negative points if you skip a
step in a math equation you're just
going to kind of completely lose all the
points sometimes in the question itself
which i think is completely ridiculous
we get golden stars and we get little
pluses above our grades when we go above
and beyond and we don't make even the
tiniest mistakes and we are told that
getting everything right will be
rewarded with you know good points with
letters about our good behavior to our
parents with spots at university and
getting the life we want rather when we
make mistakes or when we get things
wrong this is just universally bad and
is something that should be changed
immediately well i don't necessarily
think that this is the right way to
approach life and i think books may have
a much healthier kind of view of the
lessons and the experiences that you can
gain from making mistakes and i think
you have a very safe environment within
a book to see how the kind of characters
mess up their lives and do all these
terrible things i particularly love the
phrase that any fool can learn from
their own experience it's only the smart
ones that can learn from other people's
experience and i feel as though with
books we are in a way kind of testing
ourselves and putting our brains through
experiences without having to do them on
our own and more importantly than all we
are kind of shown how when other people
make mistakes they are accepted things
are fine somehow they always end up
working out in the long term while in
school i don't think this is a behavior
that is encouraged accepted or kind of
presented in any shape or form if you're
interested in developing these sort of
skills a book i would definitely
recommend is surely you're joking mr
baineman which is a book about the
physicist richard feynman and he just
messes up so much and makes so many
different mistakes and he's absolutely
hilarious so i would definitely
recommend checking that book out the
second thing i think books teach us so
much better than school is commercial
intelligence and what i mean by this
particularly is that i find it so funny
how no one expects us to kind of
discover electricity from the start
every single time no one expects us to
discover the laws of physics we just
accept that someone else did the work
beforehand they understood something
let's give this information to the new
generation so they can kind of implement
it and take it further no one kind of we
don't discover pythagoras theorem all
over again however when it comes to
emotional intelligence when it comes to
things like understanding the
consequences of trauma or understanding
our own insecurities or understanding
different forms of attachment or the way
that we kind of process our feelings and
think about the world and all this
emotional stuff that is potentially the
biggest thing that is going on in our
life is almost never even touched in
school at all which is absolutely
ridiculous we are brought into the world
shoved into social situations left to
deal with people in like school or
outside of school and left to deal with
our own minds without any sort of
expertise and experience from people in
the past on how to kind of make sense of
what's going on in our brain and the
funny thing is we have so much evidence
for this already there are so many like
if you ask a therapist they know so much
about the human brain philosophy and
psychology know so much about the human
brain but this is made so inaccessible
and so difficult to kind of reach and
understand as a student especially in
early education and even in later
education unless you are specialized in
the subjects no one ever talks about
them so i find it so frustrating that
this is not information that we are
given but we are just left to kind of i
know so many math formulas that i was
given in school that i will absolutely
never apply but i have no clue on how to
manage someone's emotions or how to
understand what pain or trauma or hurt
means for me i think it's so important
to recognize unhealthy coping mechanisms
that we may have and these sort of
skills are never taught in school so
therefore i think reading books where
you can read about the inner psychology
of characters and how they grow and how
they change and how they evolve over
different situations and very often the
authors of these books have a lot of
insight into the human mind and they can
we can see our we can see things that we
have gone through reflected in that
character and we can perhaps get advice
on how they overcame these things who
even just the knowledge that someone
else is going through the same thing i
think can be incredibly helpful for
quieting the mind and for reading this
sort of books i would just recommend
basically any sort of non-fiction at all
or if you want to go down the academic
route any sort of psychology book i
think a decent psychology but will give
you some good experience on learning
about your own brain and other people's
minds third thing that i think school
doesn't teach us is how much modern
beauty makes us miserable and this is
something i feel particularly passionate
about it's something that unless botox
talks about a lot but it's basically the
point that i think that we and i'm quite
guilty of this too
on social media or in the modern world
or in school in our education we just
glamorize and talk about the things that
are already quite fantastical to start
with but are not accessible for most
people and i think then we are left
looking at things that surround us and
feeling as though they are very mundane
and we are and we find it difficult to
look at the beauty in them well when you
read a good descriptive book you might
find that the author goes in an
incredible amount of detail about a
speck of jew that is on a leaf that is
falling outside someone's window and if
the author might even spend a whole page
or two pages just describing the effect
that this has on them and so it kind of
glamorizes the mundane and it gives you
the ability to look at your life and
look at the things around you like a
loaf of bread on your counter like the
eyelashes of the crush that you have and
see them in a completely different way
and adds so much beauty and so much
layers to the world around us and not
just to those things that we try to make
beautiful to those things that are rare
because i firmly believe that there is
so much beauty in absolutely everything
so i think romanticizing the beauty of
the world around us in a positive way
can elevate our day-to-day experience of
the world and give us the ability to see
things completely differently a great
book about this which is really based on
this concept is if no one speaks of
remarkable things which is not one of my
favorite books but i've read it because
it's quite famous
i don't know how i feel about it but
definitely would recommend virginia
woolf to the lighthouse is a great book
where it just describes basically a
single day but it goes into so much
detail about everything that happens and
it kind of gives you a completely
different perspective and just expands
every small thing that you could ever
think of in a certain day and i think it
just makes you reappreciate life number
four is that books make it easier for
you to learn because they help you let
go of your beliefs i think it was
richard feynman who said something along
the lines of i have no beliefs because
beliefs get in the way of learning and
i'm not sure i would agree with that i
think we all have beliefs and
school for example is in the business of
giving us beliefs and thoughts about how
the world works and how things work but
that does set us in a very rigid mindset
and i don't think that schools do a good
job of kind of helping us think outside
of the box or question our values or
question what we already think i don't
think that this has done very well in
school while when it comes to books i
think books do this very well in a very
sneaky way in the sense that for example
it is very very hard for us to accept a
new belief if it goes against one of our
own but it's very easy for us to think
how someone else might hold a different
belief so in a book if you're reading
about a character who sees the world
differently to you you might not agree
with what they are thinking or doing but
you can understand how they would feel
that way so through reading the book you
are putting yourself in the perspective
of this person who is completely
different and you are going through the
whole book and their whole journey with
a completely different mindset and
therefore i think that you are
unintentionally receptive and open to
learning new things taking in new
lessons seeing the world in a different
way
in such a form that would be impossible
to start with if someone just came up to
you and said hey you should think this
or you should do this i don't think that
you would ever accept this to start with
so i think books help us let go of our
beliefs even when we are not realizing
it and therefore i think they make us a
lot more open-minded and accepting of
other people's perspectives a book that
i would recommend for kind of
challenging your beliefs and the way
that you see the world is anything by
nietzsche i think that he's a great
philosopher who has some very extreme
but interesting views and it's quite a
nice challenge to
understand why he sees the world the way
he does and the last thing that i think
i'm going to mention that books give us
that school doesn't is the understanding
of things being rarely discussed but not
rare and what i mean by this is that for
example
what i mean by this is that we all have
deep dark thoughts or things that we
think are just not acceptable or at
least not socially acceptable and not
good to think but i think we can very
easily
think that these are things that would
make us a bad person and that we are
alone in feeling this way i don't think
that in school it's a good environment
either just academically or socially for
us to test the ground waters with who we
genuinely are and what we really think
while when you are reading something
it's a very safe space to see that i'm
not alone in feeling this way a lovely
example that i love a great example that
i love of this is past writing about a
young girl who was daydreaming that her
whole family would die so that she could
have the opportunity to kind of pull
herself together go right back to work
and be super strong so everyone in her
village would say oh my god that girl
just got it together so fast she's such
a strong young lady and while this girl
was daydreaming the argument of past was
not that she is an awful psychopath who
just hates her family she does love her
family and she does not want them all to
die but
she's a human and therefore she craves
social acceptance and she craves being
seen as someone who is strong and brave
and well put together and that is what
is happening in the story and i think
when past said this i think it was
mentioned in many other books as such a
good example of people reading this and
thinking oh my god i've had similar
thoughts in my past and i've definitely
had not the exact same thought but
similar thoughts in my past and i
thought that they were completely
terrible when they were younger and i
was never told that this was acceptable
or normal elsewhere but this is
something that i definitely gained from
books so it might be a very extreme case
like this or it might be just another
character going through something very
unique perhaps that no one else in your
life has gone through and getting
through it or accepting it or dealing
with it in a better or worse way than
you that makes you realize that what you
are going through is rarely discussed
but it's not actually something that
happens rarely within books i feel like
we can safely peek into the minds of
others to discover how beautifully
acceptable our thoughts are rather than
completely outrageous in a way that we
would not be able to do in real life the
last time i was mentioned in this video
is a great way to get the essence of
what books mean and the key stories and
learning points in them when you have
already read the book a long time ago
and you cannot afford to go through it
again and that is short form who are
very handy sponsoring this video the
short form is theoretically a book
summaries site however i do not use it
in that way i use it as a way to kind of
refresh my memory on different sorts of
books that i have already read before or
to test the waters with new books that
people recommend to me i've been going
through jordan peterson's 12 rules of
life on short form the reason being
quite a few people in my life very
recently have told me that i am judging
this book too harshly without having
theoretically read it so i've decided to
go through short firm first and then
potentially i'm going to read the book
itself because apparently it has been
very helpful to very many different
people and i did not feel like it was a
favorite for me but let's see i'll let
you i'll keep you updated on how that
goes there are so many different books
and different types of books on short
form i would definitely recommend the
relationships the philosophy and the
psychology segments if you are
interested in the sort of things that i
already mentioned in this video i will
have a link below where you can get free
access to short form for a limited time
but you can check out one of the books
that i mentioned if you are interested
in that there but otherwise thank you so
much for sitting through this video with
me i hope you have a wonderful rest of
the day be kind yourself and others and
don't believe everything you think
thanks bye